all right let's bring some company into
the conversation my man will blackman
former nfl defensive back super bowl
champion and and for me more more
fascinating
more interesting is he is the wine mvp
he is the wine connoisseur the wine
concierge
expert to the stars he's made one of the
most
fascinating post-career transitions of
any player that i know
which we'll get to that in a second how
you doing will man i'm good man uh
just just plugging away just grinding
it's as you mentioned with the whole
wine company
the wine mvp um just doing that man and
just
um enjoying i'm just enjoying football
too first and foremost i'm enjoying that
but
the wine business is fun right now it's
it's a grind especially starting a new
company but
um yeah lots of lots of things have been
happening in that space so i'm just
excited about it
what you excited about in the nfl so far
for two games
man i'm excited for oh look at that guy
that's like that's the most pimping
picture i've ever seen
the most michael look at that picture
listen
people get people gave me grief about my
cigar not being lit all the way i'm like
bro i took so many pictures it went out
but um now the main thing i'm excited
about i'm excited for russell wilson man
like i
it's it's his it's his year it's his
time
uh i i have them projected for him to
get his second super bowl
um i would not surprise be surprised if
he got his first mvp
but yeah i just i really love watching
that because he's he's probably the one
qb in the whole entire nfl i trust the
most so that's what i'm excited for
you know it's interesting uh will mike
smith
on this very program we talked about
quarterbacks he said hey aaron rodgers
has done it the best just in terms of
throwing the football
and just making this at its peak am i am
i representing you right
mike at the position aaron rodgers
does it the best you were teammates with
them do you buy that
100 i agree with that until
my home showed up um but you know
yeah for the whole time he's the one
person who can put the football
anywhere on the planet it doesn't matter
if he's comfortable in the pocket if
he's scrambling outside the pocket it
doesn't matter where it is he's the
ultimate conductor
uh in that space so that is not way off
i told
i can agree with that but right now i
think it's always between him and my
homes in terms of who can do the most
with their arm
so that's what it is it's the arm talent
slight slight edge you give to my home
so i was going to ask you how do you
distinguish between these two because
they're very similar in a lot of
respects no they're very similar
because it's funny because aaron rodgers
he's he's older now so
uh people forget like all these crazy
wild throws that my home's just doing is
is what exactly what aaron rodgers did
younger in his career um is to make
these just crazy
wild insane i mean his first touchdown
in 2008
uh versus the vikings on monday night
football his he was falling backwards
and threw it on the side
and it's actually it's very similar to
what mahomes did this past weekend
same thing rolling out to your right and
then threw it across body so
as as much as we love the young gun with
patching with homes
aaron rodgers is still is still doing
that stuff
you know well i was proud of myself the
other day
i think it was yesterday i was talking
to mike and i and we're talking about
black quarterbacks in the league i want
to ask you about that
uh but we were going back and i said hey
you know i it really moved me in 1987
and i
this easily seamlessly incorporated
washington football team we're talking
about doug williams
not the old name now i know you played
in washington
how do you feel about this change and
and
how did you feel when you were playing
for that team and and
that was the name of the team that you
played for what was that like
yeah you know it was it was interesting
um i mean i grew up
just that's what it was you know it's
almost like when we talk about other
you know touchy subjects where people
don't know any different
so growing up the washington redskins
that was a team um
my my mother's side the family they're
heavily uh
heavily uh influenced a native american
background uh now against indian to be
exact and
her side has a reservation and
everything in rhode island but i never
really
thought about the history and details
for the fact that the name has been
around for so long so i
just didn't think it was a big deal but
just being there
playing for the team it was very very
different because
it was just more it was more about the
organization than it was
football and it looks like now in this
case they're trying to really
take care of the infrastructure and make
sure that it's about football
because if you want to make change in
anything that's going on it's a
systematic situation it doesn't matter
what it is nothing's going to get done
and it has to be the people in power who
want to get things done so
i can definitely see a huge shift in
what's going on
um with the with the washington football
team and ron rivera came in and part of
his
uh process he's like well there's
certain people in this building that i
don't want i don't want here if you want
me to be on this team too or coach this
team so
um i'm i'm very pleased to like where
they're going where they're headed from
a
fan's perspective and you got dwayne
haskins as a starter he opposed colin
murray
another guy that's set in the league on
fire by the way through two weeks
uh opposed kyle murray uh last week so
that was one of
four match-ups all-time record
among uh african-american starting
quarterbacks
and then you talk about i think the
total is 10
black quarterbacks starting in the nfl
right now like what is that number
uh what is the changing face of the
position and by the way well as you know
not just starting not just holding down
jobs where you look at lamar
and desean and patrick in particular and
even russ all
right he's been doing it longer
obviously but all revolutionizing the
position and the way that it's played
yeah i mean the that position has
definitely um
became more athletic because as as
evolution shows the game has always
changed from different perspectives now
the
the one constant will always remain is
that you have to be able to
sit in the pocket and throw the football
and these are these things that these
athletic quarterbacks able to do uh
russell is his running is so
underrated and that's something he can
do very very well um but he also can sit
there and throw for 400 yards or 305 tds
like he did the other night
same thing with my homes deshawn watson
so all these qb's can throw for 300 400
yards
which makes them uh an even more serious
there because before that you know you
had a guy who
quarterback will run for over 100 yards
maybe throw for two something but these
cubies now i can throw for 300 plus so
that's what makes them super dangerous
well man i need your help you know i i
like to drink a little wine every now
and then i just do
you're going to ask the question i knew
what's happening i'm going there
and as my back i need some help tonight
he charges for this
hey man he charged for this night he
don't get us out for free you got a
business today
you got me on the show i can't charge
you're helping me out he's going to help
me out a little bit he'll help me out a
little bit but no seriously
uh just how did you get into the wine
mvp
just tell us the story of how that
happened it's a great name i love the
pictures just tell us that story
yeah so i initially uh you know started
enjoying wine
just on my own uh just consuming it and
then it wasn't until i got drafted to
the packers
when i found out that um charles woodson
who actually was signed the same year
that he was actually in the wine
business
and he will always take our group the
defensive backs out to dinner you know
on away games but i really got to
understand like okay this
he's someone like me african-american
guy
nfl player who's in the wine business
and i thought i was interesting so
um i try to educate myself and trying to
learn more and that's something that's
very very hard to do on your own
and so that's when you know i started
taking all of these um
certification courses i took the wine
and spirits education trust i just
finished my level three
in that and my exams coming up soon uh i
passed my quarter masters
uh love intro level one somalia exam
and then i was like man i initially want
to have my own wine label but i feel
like everyone was doing that and i was
like
everyone i asked they said
you need to be able to sell the wine
first and foremost i don't care what you
do so i'm like okay i started doing more
research
and i also had a lot of guys reach out
to me like hey man you know what should
i get what should i buy and that's where
kind of light bulb went off maybe i
should start doing some kind of
concierge thing because
um and really educate these people on on
these different wine brands so that's
when
i originally came up with nfl wine guy
but i think because of the acronym nfl
i'm sure i was going to get a letter
so me and my buddy patrick he's my
creative director we decided to come up
with the wine mvp
which i thought was great man because it
crosses over to every single sport
basically you anyone could be the one
mvp
the mvp of wine with the right education
and that's basically how
how i got into it so it's been cool man
i've been
just to start off you know right when
kobe had everybody wanted their shell
was filled up so
um matt ryan was one of the first people
who i helped out
uh you know carry his seller i did
reggie bush i did his entire seller
um justin tuck um right now
josh allen he just he just finished
building he actually lives
close by me and in cali and he just
finished he just texted me his brand new
seller so when he comes back out here
i'm gonna go there and help him out uh
so it's justin tuck he's another one
so it's been cool you know just to be in
that space and now
uh i'm on zooms every morning with you
know
regions and france and italy i had to
finally get a whatsapp because
you know i got to be able to talk to
these people daily um without getting
blasted with a phone charge so
it's been cool man the next step is to
curate uh a trip you know once it's safe
to do so to these one of these regions
and i spoke to a lot of guys
in the sports industry that are totally
down for it so it's been really cool
getting support
uh it's been cool to watch man i mean
you and i you know i feel like i've
known me forever but we just really
started you know
started talking within the last several
months or whatever and just
you know wine has become very trendy
uh you know in sports but like this is
this is something i mean just that's a
gloss over this
you were one of wine enthusiasts 40
under 40. that's where
that pimpin picture comes from you are
about to be a level three somalia like
you have devoted your life to this and
and so it's just impressive the business
you've built
the reputation you built by the way
should be one of those masks dawg like i
got the wine but i didn't get the mess
with it
but anyway yeah yeah give me a mass
but but honestly we're asking oh yeah
absolutely
but broader though what i want to ask
you about will is you see so many
players
you know because it's a fascinating uh
life experience professional athletes
have is you spend your whole life
devoting it to a craft in a career that
you know if you're lucky you get to play
until you're 30. a lot of guys struggle
with transitions but not only have you
flourished
post playing career but you found a
passion and somebody to
something to really pour yourself into
you know what's that part of this been
like for you just
this being your calling as opposed to
just a hobby to keep you occupied
yeah i always say that there's two
transitions for any pro athlete that's
very difficult
you know the first transition is your
transition into the sport
because in my case you know i'm in
college i don't have any bills i'm not
paying anything
you know like free meals room and board
all that stuff as soon as you get
drafted
your responsibility is to play football
but once you leave the building
you got you have to buy a house you got
to buy a car you have bills you have all
these things
that you have to pay for and you have to
be a responsible adult
adult and that's a difficult part you
have to grow up right now
the second most challenging part too is
once you leave the game it's like taking
the hamster off the wheel you're so used
to doing everything
the same all the time like you know i've
been playing football from ages
6 to 34 years old and
for me to leave that it's like
it's like now what you know sure i can
go coach you know
uh i guess i'm considered expert i can
go coach i can go work in the front
office i can
do these things even work on tv but like
the biggest thing is like what's going
to move me
because i can easily do these things and
end up
kind of getting over it you know what
i'm saying because i football is the
only thing i ever wanted to do
period people can say yeah i majored in
english but in reality i majored in
football when i was at boston college
because that's what i was trying to do
and ended up achieving that and the
thing that made me fall in love with
football was i fell in love with the
history of the game my father used to
show me these old school
uh vhs tapes with you know john
fasenda's voice
and samus you know saying like i used to
watch
all that stuff and i fell in love with
barry sanders when i was four years old
and the crazy thing about it is when i
started watching all these documentaries
with wine i was like man i fell in love
with the history of the wine it was
never about
yeah i take cool pictures do it for the
gram but it was never about the
lifestyle for me man it was about the
history
the tradition that's why i'm really big
on the education
part when i'm talking about wine so
you know i kind of found i found that
that niche that void
where you know my demographic they're so
used to the craft spirits and the
seltzers and all the fun stuff like that
however they're still paying for
high-end luxury goods
so the space where everyone in the world
is reaching out to me is because
these old-school premium wineries that
have rich history
they're trying to find a way to connect
with the younger demographic and they're
calling me to be that person to do so so
i like when i'm teaching football i do
the same thing i teach them about the
history like
it like it never really changes it
evolves in terms of the people but the
essence is true
same thing with wine the essence is true
and that's that's why i'm
you know head over heels full fledge
like you said this is not
a hobby this is real life i'm every day
i'm on a meeting
uh trying to get this thing right you
know well i i'm i'm happy for you
i'm proud of this the last thing i have
for you and i'm so glad that you had a
12-year nfl career
cause i don't know if you know this
story uh i used to do sports radio in
boston
and your brother said to me hey
yeah my brother my brother's at boston
college you should give him some love
he's going to be drafted
so i went on the air i was like hey
watch out will blackman
he's going to be drafting i did it like
a couple days in a row then your brother
reached out to me again he said i need
you to stop you're going too far i don't
want you to mess it up
so look hey let him know nothing got
messed up not only did you have a dozen
year career in the nfl but you're doing
great now
in the space that you're in that's great
mvp.com go there there it is that's
where everything is
appreciate you will yeah thank you man
so much man appreciate it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports